be sure to follow me on instagram there
you can hang out with me and talk to me
directly
okay so we are getting back into Batman
Superman like we're getting back into
Batman Superman in the last video we
basically ended that on like Superman
busting into the prison but beneath the
Hall of Justice or the Batman who lost
is being held and then in turn like
breaking him out right and so the big
question is this this is kind of the
question that we ended this on you know
is it is it Superman full-on infected or
is it Superman working on behalf of
Batman and the circumstances lent
themselves to the idea the Superman was
working with Batman and this was all
just one great big ruse and and that's
really what it turns out to be right it
really just turned out to be a
circumstance where Superman infected
himself with the Joker toxin in order to
go underground I guess in order to
infiltrate and to trick the Batman who
lasts into believing that he has
successfully been infected and so
basically like this prison break or at
least the a breaking him out of this
facility is one of the worst-case
scenarios in a lot of ways because what
it means is the Batman who lasts is on
the loose again but the other half of
this and the reason why this is so
interesting is because a Superman
playing a dangerous game now is one of
these things where Superman's kind of
like okay so like we couldn't get the
plan for Billy Batson like like you know
what's what's his plan like what's the
scheme that you have and the way the
Batman who laughs does this is it's kind
of hilarious right because I was reading
through this and I was like what is like
one of the most grandiose schemes in the
history of everything right like it'd be
it's kind of an insane scheme but at the
same time it sounds like it'd be nothing
the Batman who last would do because
what he says here is like my scheme I my
grand plan here is to infect all the
superheroes of your world and then like
infect everybody in your multiverse and
then like destroy your multiverse and
it's just kind of like really that's
your that's your grand scheme by this
your grand plan is to wipe everything
out of existence and he actually ends up
going as far as might on Superman and be
like you know like your mom felt when
your world exploded that's how you're
gonna feel it's almost like he's touring
with the Man of Steel and the reason why
is because if soon as Superman basically
reveals a fact that he's not fully
turned right he lets his temper get the
better of him and starts tearing into
the the Batman who lasts ultimately
Batman jumps in with kryptonite and
stops Superman and that's when you find
out they never broke out right like they
never broke out of the facility like
they've they've been in there the entire
time they're Superman just walked in
there so this perception that like the
Batman who last had been broken out this
believes that like he was on the loose
again that none of it was real but
here's a funny thing about this is the
Batman who lasts new it's kind of this
revelation of like hey he knows what's
going on right like that's why he's
taunting you that's why he's toying with
you that's why he's using you is because
like he knows that all this
but he knows that all this is a trick
and so he leaves them one last clue you
know when they ask him like who are the
secret six that you infected as if it's
gonna do anything is if it's going to
like help it all you know it's going to
help with anything they asked him like
you know who who were the secret six
that you infected and any lashes like
I'm not gonna tell you guys who it is
Ike I'm not gonna reveal all the names
I'll just tell you like I wouldn't shine
their name in the sky with a light you
know and right off the bat Batman
immediately figures out who this person
is right so drop Superman in this giant
facility where it'll basically bombard
him with solar radiation and it'll have
to essentially you know get rid of the
Joker toxin now here's the thing about
that right like the more I stand out the
more I think about it this way here's
the thing about that if if joke I'm
sorry if Superman was infected with the
toxin of the Joker from the DC Universe
right not even the might even Batman
you'll ask the main DC Universe and he
was cured of it it would stand to reason
to following that Batman would use his
intellect to figure out how to adopt a
faster cure to find a way to basically
cleanse the Joker toxin from Superman as
fast as possible plus you know yellow
sunlight you know no I guess it really I
mean the only other alternative besides
that it's just like put Superman in a
capsule it'll shoot him into the Sun ah
the problem is you know I mean he kind
of needs him and so basically racing
over to Gotham City this is one of the
things I like about this because
Williamson does not ignore some of the
stuff that happened in the Batman who
laughs right like that's one of the
things that you guys will see when it
comes to two different crossovers those
are guys who were new to comics and
people who have been around in comics
for a long time will tell you this is
true and it is the bane of almost any
comic book fans existence right like
it's the one thing we hate them mostly
is it's the one thing that people are
pissed off not with Brian Michael Bendis
which rightfully so because Menace is
ready Superman that basically ignored
everything that was done or you know in
actually comics ended and Superman
before him which kind of sucks because
it was some amazing storage have like
fed were pissed but but still you know
like it's one of those things where
writers will come along and they'll
ignore the work before them they'll
ignore the previous work and then like
fans will kind of feel like they're left
hanging right because they're kind of
they're part of this like cohesive story
and then suddenly it just gets cut off
it pisses us off to no end to be honest
this is really what it is but but this
basically picks up after the events or
at least it really ties into the
conclusion of the Batman who lasts
because what we saw is the end of that
story is that the person who was
infected was Commissioner Gordon and
that Commissioner Gordon wasn't
that the first person in the main DC
Universe to be infected by the Batman
who laughs right like I mean I guess
it's not when Batman himself you know
following following that like you
Richard Gordon was the first one to be
infected and he's been infected the
entire time and you end up learning the
whole thing was a ruse right when he was
like Batman Superman come help some kids
been kidnapped and you know you track
him down that none of that was real that
it was all basically just like this big
scheme there was part of the big scheme
that was thought of by the Batman who
laughs in order to put Batman a Superman
one to work together to get them to
isolate themselves and three like to
basically infect Billy Batson I suppose
it's it's solid insofar as Commissioner
Gordon is is probably a person that you
wouldn't expect now the big question to
ask here is why was Commissioner Gordon
infected like of all the people to
infect why Commissioner Gordon because
what can he do right I mean he can do
like like what King Commissioner Gordon
do in this scenario that could really
change the game right they could really
put things in a circumstance where it
would somehow like change the landscape
right like why Commissioner Gordon
because he's basically just a guy who's
a cop the cool thing about this comes in
the form of Superman who basically says
the Batman who laughs just wanted to
prove he could infect your closest
friend that he could get to that you
could get to the people closest to you
but here's the--here's kind of the issue
with that like here's the issue that I
have with that and I don't mean for this
is turned like a great week huge
criticism of the Batman a Batman of
Superman but by no means like I love
this story to death but here's the
here's one of the things that kind of
strikes me as strange about that is that
was basically already established that
like the Joe the Batman who last can hit
you closest to home right now that was a
whole idea behind the entire Batman who
lasts miniseries like there's no safe
place right like if he wants to come to
you or the people you care about
he will right so that's already
established it may just be one of those
things where Williamson is kind of
establishing that for people who never
read the Batman who laughs miniseries
which I don't know why you wouldn't it's
an amazing miniseries but like anybody
who didn't read that kind of bring that
in but what it does do is it basically
says that like the individuals who are
being infected by the Batman alas it's
being done for strategic purpose right
so I don't think it's simply just
because of the fact that this
Commissioner Gordon and he's a really
good friend of Batman I think there's
other reasons behind this I think
there's a there's a bigger motivation
behind this in terms of why Commissioner
Gordon was infected here now here's the
other cool thing that kind of comes out
of this is you end up having like one of
these mech suits it comes to sitting
down on - on the Batman to Superman
Superman uses frost breath and freezes
it now somebody here correct me if I'm
wrong I may very well be but somebody
correct me if I'm wrong we haven't seen
Superman uses frost breath
for quite some time right I wouldn't go
as far as to make the statement and say
that it that like he hasn't done it like
in the entirety of new 52 or DC rebirth
I'm not gonna make that statement I mean
I'm honestly I can't remember that far
back but I feel like we haven't seen him
do it over the course of rebirth I mean
it's it's kind of cool to see to be
honest with you guys like it's cool to
see him use as Frost with I don't know
maybe use it recently I'm not I'm not a
hundred percent sure I don't remember
him using it during venice's unity saga
I don't remember seeing him do it before
Bennett's took over on Batman or
Superman I remember seeing him do that
like I don't I don't recall that it's
just kind of a cool little small thing
to see Jim Gordon's taken out pretty
pretty quickly why be sneaking out twice
swiftly and that was the expectation
because what this does is it forces
Batman to think differently you know his
response here is okay if the Batman who
laughs thinks like me then it's time for
me to stop thinking like me and it's
hard for you to something like him right
because it creates a circular pattern if
Batman sits down and says okay so the
Batman who laughs is basically me I'm
gonna think like him which is thinking
like me which is thinking like him it
creates a circular pattern where he
never gets out of it so it's like let's
nip that in the bud let's think like
what Superman would do what would the
Superman do like what would he do in
this circumstance and it's really kind
of cool to see because what it is is
it's Batman basically deferring to
Superman's logic is Batman deferring to
him and say okay like one we're gonna
take Commissioner Gordon to the fortress
of solitude where nobody else can get in
here right where everything else will be
fine and then like we'll go with what
Superman would do here because it's the
Batman who lasts not the Superman who
lasts right so it's kind of a cool thing
the problem with this is that
Commissioner Gordon was a Trojan horse
that's exactly what Commissioner Gordon
was Commissioner Gordon was designed to
was was basically he was that's the
reason why he's here is because he knew
that that that Batman wouldn't kill him
right the Batman he last knew that Bruce
Wayne would not kill Commissioner Gordon
he's gotta take Commissioner Gordon to a
place where he believes the Batman will
who last can't get to him which would be
the fortress of solitude right because
the only people who can get in there or
people who are explicitly given access
by Superman right you can't just have
any swinging dick walking up to the
forces of solitude as being like Open
Sesame
and then like it opens up and they walk
in otherwise what would be the full
movie the Virgin's are calling it a
fortress it'd just be like you know a
giant place in solitude is what it would
be called like you know a relatively
well hidden location in in solitude that
gotta be where you would have to call it
uh the idea here is that would that be
the case of the Batman who lasts knowing
that and
Bruce would make that move that leads to
him bring Commissioner Gordon to to the
fortress of solitude which in turn
basically brings out Jaime Reyes now
here's the thing all right here's your's
the interesting thing about this I feel
like Jaime Ray's fans are probably gonna
like hit the roof and be insanely happy
and rightfully so
right because here's here's the thing
about Jaime Reyes Jaime Reyes I think
was really really cool after Infinite
Crisis basically when he popped up you
know when he became like the new the new
Blue Beetle he was really cool as part
of that whole story the issue with Jaime
Reyes is I feel like in recent years
he's kind of just gotten the rebuff
right it's just kind of like he's a guy
who's there they should watch a guy's
piece like that's basically it when it
comes to heavy rains like you don't
really get much with it you know the
like DC hasn't really pushed him all
that hard and then the cool thing about
this is that having him being brought in
as a person who's infected by the Batman
who lasts what it does is really kind of
williamson's way of saying hey look guys
you guys have been sleeping on Jaime
Reyes like that's really what's been
going on here right and in reality
people are like people don't really
understand how powerful Jaime Reyes can
be at a post Infinite Crisis there were
multiple circumstances where it was
kinda like hey look if this guy pushed
his powers to the limit right like it's
him in the Scarab push the powers to the
limit and basically take all this tech
and all this energy that makes up what
what it is that Blue Beetle can do and
then like push it to an absolute peak
they got would be an absolute powerhouse
in in DC Comics and there are times that
he has been but the fact remains that at
the moment right now like because of the
nature of the Blue Beetle suit because
it's basically a high-tech suit that's
used by by Jaime Reyes by virtue of the
Scarab this grafted to his back he could
infiltrate virtually anything and being
able to like put him in a circumstance
where he basically becomes this kind of
you know where Commissioner Gordon acts
as as as a as a Trojan horse which
allows Jaime Reyes to basically like
infiltrate the the tech systems of the
fortress of solitude and then take them
all over to essentially take over
Kryptonian technology makes them like
this hugely dangerous foe because now
it's basically like Jaime Reyes
amped up with with with like Kryptonian
technology that has to face off against
Batman vs Superman and the guys totally
insane at the same time that's kind of
the crazy thing because what this does
this is one of the weird this is one of
the crazy things about this is that what
this does looking at the depiction of
the suit as it shows up at the end of
this it doesn't really look like it's
Jaime Reyes in control the reason why I
say that is in DC Comics one of the
things that they established is that
this scarab can actually seize control
and totally take over absent Jaime Reyes
right so it's so it almost becomes this
kind of Bruce Banner incredible whole
thing right you know we're like The
Incredible Hulk takes over a Bruce
Banner can't really stop him ah it's
it's similar to that not identical but
it's something akin to that but the
Scarab basically takes over and becomes
like it literally grows in size it
becomes bigger it gets like these spikes
and all this crazy stuff looking on his
back that's kind of how it looks at the
moment you know now again this is
probably one of those circumstances
where this form is achieved by the two
of them working in tandem because they
both been infected right I mean affected
with a joker toxin because of the fact
that the Scarab is grafted to the spine
of Jaime Reyes you infect one you infect
the other righty you can't really get
away with only infecting one of them and
then the other ones just kind of there
as a result of that Batman is Superman
are taken out quick fast and in a hurry
but being able to infiltrate Kryptonian
technology in turn allows Jaime Reyes to
infiltrate the rest of the world's
technology right to infiltrate the Hall
of Heroes and all that kind of stuff and
this is this is one of the cool things
that goes on here is because what this
does is it ties into villains of the
year it's highs into Scott Snyder's
Justice League because those you guys
who are watching scott Snyder's Justice
League you have Lex Luthor who's
basically the apex predator now like
this do they call him a human if you
want to the way that he was originally
created when the multiverse was first
formed before it was wiped away and then
replaced with everything we've basically
been seeing since like you know the
formation of DC Comics in the modern era
as a result of that like he's he's he's
uh he's basically like a Martian
Manhunter
and a human being merged into one is
really what it is right that's how
people originally work but he's also
leading his Legion of Doom and the
Legion of Doom is one of these things
were kind of like trying to seize
control like ensure the survival of
Perpetua and so what this means what
this shows is the Batman who last is on
a collision course with Lex Luthor's
forces here's the question I have is the
enemy of my enemy my friend that's my
question that I'm asking here is because
if that's the case then what I would
love to see come out of this is even if
it's only for a temporary alliance right
like Batman Superman the Batman who
laughs in the secret six working
together against the forces of Lex
Luthor that would be legit like that
would do that would be falling cuz I
don't you imagine like here's the thing
imagine what would happen if the Batman
and the Batman who laughs teamed up with
each other like imagine what that would
look like like nobody would stand a
chance
they'd be like super Batman basically it
it'd be super Batman just wreaking havoc
on whoever he fights it'd be pretty cool
give me pretty salt but nonetheless uh
with that being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here - comments explaining sure you
guys are the sub
to become part of the Robin Court if you
guys enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later peace
[Music]
[Music]